foreign
[Music]
must be eliminated
they took everything from us
I was trained in their ways their
technology
their weapons
things that are not be should not know
and then one day
they left Hell's Gate is under attack
evacuate now
but before they did our teacher saved us
and put us to sleep this is your only
chance to survive
and there I remained for 15 years
until one day
I awoke
[Music]
and I was free
free to explore my world
[Music]
free to decide who I was going to be
cover what I was meant to do
Pandora is under attack again
don't let the Navi get in our way get
rid of them and I have a choice to make
I choose to protect my home
[Music]
foreign
s
[Music]
I am not me
[Applause]
hi there everyone I'm Jim Cameron the
creator of Avatar and Avatar the way of
water
in developing both of these films I set
out to imagine another world a world is
Rich and complex as our own
and we wanted the audience to feel as
though they were really on Pandora to
dream with their eyes wide open and to
explore this world with our characters
and it's always been our vision to
embrace technology to allow us to find
new ways outside the cinema to immerse
people in this world
our friends at Ubisoft share the same
ambition and the team at massive have
been pushing the boundaries of what's
possible in games to bring a new corner
of Pandora to life
so with Avatar frontiers of Pandora our
creative team at light storm has been
able to share their insights with
massive talented team who are experts in
creating living open worlds
together we'll be able to bring players
to the Western frontier with new
environments new flora and fauna new
characters and an original story that
coexists with the events of the Avatar
films
we can't wait for you to join this
adventure and we look forward to
welcoming you back to the world of
Avatar once again
[Music]
hello everyone
my name is Steven dainfeld and ask the
game director I'm proud to be
representing the team behind Avatar
frontiers of Pandora today and excited
to share a sneak peek of what we've been
working on
in this all new story you'll set out on
a journey of Discovery to unravel the
mysteries of your past learn what it
means to be Navi and explore new parts
of Pandora on land or together with your
trusted Banshee in the air
our ambition is to create a playground
where curiosity is rewarded this
tangible and highly immersive
first-person experience will allow you
to closely connect to a beautiful open
world touch and interact with it using
your size your superhuman strength and
your natural agility to gain the upper
hand
let's rise to the challenge on December
7th
until then
we're delighted to show you a glimpse of
this adventure so prepare to lose
yourselves in the Beauty and the danger
of the Western frontier
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Avatar frontiers of Pandora a
first person action adventure game that
invites you to explore the engaging
world of Avatar in an immersive open
World Experience I'm Dede deanfeldt game
director and I'm excited to reveal
what's waiting for you on Pandora
game begins when the RDA expands their
operations to the Western frontier
John Mercer one of the leaders of the
RDA abducts you and other Navi children
from your home to teach you the ways of
humans hoping to mold you and Turn you
against your own people
but his plan is interrupted by the
battle of the Hallelujah mountains and
you are put into emergency cryosleep
when you awaken 15 years later you are a
stranger in your birthplace
knowing the dangers posed by the RDA you
set out to take them down and look to
secure the health of other Navi Clans
initially you're perceived as an
outsider so you have to reconnect with
your lost Navi Heritage to gain their
trust
on your adventure you'll find your own
path as you discover what it means to be
Navi you'll explore new regions of
Pandora each with their own unique
biomes
the king Law Forest is a lush rainforest
brimming with life and dense vegetation
in the shade of awe-inspiring floating
mountains
this is the home of the Arana hay a clan
of peaceful Weavers who will guide you
on your first hunt and on your first
flight
show you the way to The Rookery where
you can bond for life with your very own
ekram
the ikram is a devoted companion that
you can name feed and customize
experiment with acrobatics and feel a
rush of adrenaline as you dive from the
sky and explore the open world of
Pandora from the air if you travel North
you'll get to the upper Plains
an expansive grassland filled with
contrasts and open views as far as the
eye can see
the nomadic sesuit Clan live here in
symbiosis with gigantic beasts called
sakuru
earn the Clan's trust and they will
teach you the art of riding dire horses
further west the mysterious clouded
Forest
were hidden in the Mist
nothing is as it seems
here is the cemetery a clan of healers
with their own dark reasons to stay
hidden
RDA operations are threatening the
balance of Pandora
they build facilities of all Sciences to
exploit resources at any cost spreading
devastating pollution
in the process animals are hurt and
poached
you'll need to stop the RDA from
ravaging your home and when you are
ready you will take the fight to them
as a child of Two Worlds you can learn
to master multiple combat Styles your
powerful instincts allow you to get an
overview of the battlefield Mark your
enemies and identify weak points
traditional Navi weapons are versatile
and precise you can use the Longbow to
hit long-range targets or the staff's
link to set up traps
for a more explosive approach you can
leverage your human training and go for
the blast of an assault rifle a shotgun
or go bigger with the occasional rocket
launcher
on foot you can also rely on your
Incredible strength to take down amp
units above the clouds your ikron will
help you in aerial combat against the
RDA
destroying RDA facilities will have a
tangible impact on your world
with the pollution removed Pandora heals
you'll be able to harvest the best
quality material again and craft better
gear and weapons
you will also find ingredients to cook
and make meals to get stronger
as you keep discovering what it truly
means to become Navi you'll improve your
skills by connecting to Aya through the
tarshu plant and learn from the memories
of your ancestors
upgrades can improve many aspects of
your character such as your natural
agility to move through the world your
stealth approach when hunting or
fighting or the handling of your weapons
and mounts
Avatar frontiers of Pandora is a
captivating action-adventure game
designed to maximize the power of new
gen consoles and PC
you will be able to play the full story
campaign in single player
or with a friend online in two-player
Co-op
we invite you to explore this world of
wonder
come Navi
take down the RDA to protect Pandora
really good
[Music]
let's go Chad let's get it baby you have
some fun with it
another gun
another one this feels great
I got two
oh my God
I'm going crazy
you should knew it
was good
yes oh my shield
okay yeah this scope is so good
oh my God
gentle yeah now I'm losing flaw right
now
oh this game's fun man I don't know
this game's great I missed some critical
damage what about you
sadness I'm so excited about this game
in general hey I love like the pacing of
the game though
foreign
[Music]
hello hello my name is Mark Rubin
executive producer on X defiant uh what
you just saw was a collection of live
clips and reactions from players
streaming our game during our closed
beta test in April and we've been
absolutely overwhelmed by the amazing
response to our game from players all
over the world
now for us Community has really been the
core of this game's development and
we've had 28 public tests so far with
the recent closed beta being the largest
and of course the first with no NDA
and throughout all of these tests we've
done our best to listen and respond to
the feedback of players
so thank you so much to the more than
one and a half million players who have
participated in those tests and the
countless creators and streamers who
shared their footage and feedback about
X defiant
now we're ready to look towards the
future
we are currently planning on launching
later this summer
but before we do that we will be holding
another test to address some of the
feedback from the closed beta this Open
Session will be available to everyone on
PC PS5 and Xbox series X and S from June
21st to June 23rd
this is a short test
but we are opening it to everyone to get
as much feedback as possible on our new
net code our controller tuning and of
course to stress out the servers as much
as possible
so if you have not played X Define it
yet this is your chance
but let's talk about what's going to
happen when we launch later this summer
we will start with a six week preseason
that will have all of our launch content
with 14 Maps five factions 24 weapons
and much much more
we then move into our year One content
schedule which is packed with some
really exciting content with four brand
new meta changing factions each with
unique characters and skills 12 new
weapons and 12 new maps that's one new
map every month all inspired by
ubisoft's amazing worlds
and I think you may really be surprised
at where we go
year one is really going to have a lot
of great gameplay content all focused on
creating a Fun Arcade FPS experience
and we are committed to staying true to
our community and to strive to make X
defiant the best place to compete and
have fun
now it's been quite the journey to get
to this point so thank you again to all
the players that supported X Defiance so
far and for everyone who hasn't yet had
the chance we hope to see you in game
soon
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
faster
[Applause]
hi everyone it's so exciting to be with
you today
about 30 years ago in 1989
I discovered a great action adventure
game both challenging my skills and
respecting my cleverness
it was Prince of Persia
game director of Prince of Persia the
Lost crown
[Applause]
time has come to open a new chapter and
to journey in legendary Persia in an era
but the laws of Mortals were ruled by
The Laws of Gods
you are Saga a Fearless sword Prodigy
the youngest member of a squad of seven
Elite Royals The Immortals
one night Prince Hassan sawhead with
Throne is adopted and taken to her
hostile and cursed land mom calf
you and your brothers in hands are sent
on a race commission to save Prince
Hassan
however this assignment will cast you
straight into the lion's den
and it is here but you Saigon and the
whole Kingdom
must prepare to face the greatest threat
of your lies
this is your story in Mount calf you're
Destiny awaits
[Music]
when entering Mount calf your mission is
clear find Prince Hassan and bring him
back to perseverance
however mankath becomes a prison full of
hostile inhabitants
now separated from your allies we
discover a grand Citadel full of
mysteries where time flows differently
what is this sorcery the past coexists
with the future
in discussed land exploration is
everything
since semi-open world that delivers new
Secrets as you find new power
but to reach new areas you have to
master your skills and your sense of
timing
a trademark of Prince of Persia
during this Epic Journey you won't be
the only one trapped in montcast
I'm blacksmith to the Gods
some dealers are willing to help you
While others are more reluctant
[Music]
but sagon is a salt man like no other
on the battlefield
by anger take constantly puts his life
on the line but from devastating attacks
foreign
powers are back
but this time
how was that not only in your hands
face such a challenge Master a new side
of this time for us
and defy gravity
by combining all these kids together you
can express your creativity
to solve montcast Mysteries
and execute brutal combos in Epic
combats
and
that's just
a glimpse of what Prince of Persia the
Lost Crown is all about
I'd like to thank men tricks who
composed the in-game music you are just
listening to
and of course my fantastic team at
Ubisoft Montpellier
we cannot wait for you to get your hands
on the game it releases on January 18
2024 on all platform
thank you and enjoy the rest of the show
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
my name is Addie Shankar I'm a TV and
movie producer you may know me from the
Castlevania animated series on Netflix
or one of my fan fiction shorts on
YouTube
seven years ago I got a call from
Ubisoft offering me the opportunity to
adapt one of their uh very very very
serious franchises into an anime
but instead I came back to them with a
crazy concept inspired by the the mood
of Far Cry 3 blood Dragon
this concept used ubisoft's vast library
of characters and remixed them into one
Delirious anime series
that would become This Love Letter to
the 90s
or at least how I remember the 90s
and to my absolute surprise Ubisoft said
no
[Laughter]
hahaha
just kidding they said yes
so I am up here
come on
this is
worry of how the first anime series by
Ubisoft was born
Captain laser Hawk
a blood dragon remix
this show is many things
it's violent
it's a dystopian fiction in the spirit
of the works of Aldous Huxley it's a
spoof it's a satire
it's dark comedy
it's a love story
and as a descendant of Indian Mystics
I can tell you it's the most
philosophically conscious
show
you've watched in a long time
the series was picked up by Netflix
it was animated by the Renegade genius
Pirates at Bobby pills Studio
and today
I'm very happy to announce that barring
an apocalypse
which may happen
it will be released worldwide later this
year
and that's not all
I'm even more excited to share with you
an action-packed Easter egg filled
teaser trailer right now
[Applause]
don't change the channel
[Music]
all right
Join the Revolution
Let's do let's do
foreign
[Music]
get ready
foreign
[Music]
rocket
[Applause]
[Music]
bro
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you guys thank you everyone
five years ago recruit you took off now
each month's millions of field Seekers
just like you
I enjoying playing eager to see what's
next
I am stefanberry creative director of
the crew
thanks
[Applause]
today at last it is my pleasure to
introduce the future of the crew murder
first
our own new take on the action driving
gendra a celebration for car lovers to
share and experience conquered to your
fantasy on the beautiful island of wow
in a way
no matter how you enjoy girls and
driving on your own or weave your crew
motorfest has something for everyone
more fast your bottle to medley of high
octane experiences you choose how you
like to have fun with your cause
this is what more of his playlists are
all about
playlists are truly at the heart of
photo first
want to immerse yourself in the most
exciting words of kakuchi
dive
into a legacy of the world's most
influential automakers
light up the knights street racing scene
Japanese style
unleash The Cutting Edge power of
electric
Super Girls
and this is just a taste
for the first time ever we'll leave the
U.S Mainland behind our Festival has
landed in one of the most breathtaking
and vibrant places on Earth
Oahu let's find out why Oahu is the
perfect playground
for driving fell
race through the city street of Honolulu
Power It Up
black cash covered slopes
Adventure deep into Lush rainforests
are Cruiser Jews at Sunset with your
friends
opportunities for fun and challenges are
endless
a unique playground like this course for
profusion of vehicles
choose and customize your ride
who is one of the most diverse lineups
ever
from past
present
and
future
recognize the latest from Lamborghini I
think so yeah I know you are as real as
I am to get behind the wheel of his
Beauty
hey some of you I spend a lot of energy
building the perfect Baker collection in
the crew 2. in a few weeks you will be
able to import your vehicle connection
into the crew model fast for free
thanks
[Applause]
so stay tuned for more news about the
correction Imports and our complete
Festival program later this month during
our summer showcase
since the beginning of the year
thousands of players have tested the
game and giving us Priceless feedback
Through The Insider program
join the party register now for close
beta and share with the world your
experience
in July
from the entire team at Ubisoft avoid
over
Mahalo thank you welcome to motherfest
enjoy the ride
[Applause]
[Music]
you're the best
and can't handle us
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hi everyone
I hope you enjoyed that first look at
this exciting new way to play Assassin's
Creed
coming to meta Quest this holiday
Assassin's Creed Nexus will push the
boundaries of VR and let you become the
Assassin
you will feel what it means to parkour
fight and be stealthy in new memories
from three legendary assassins Ezio
Cassandra and Conor
I cannot wait to see our players feel
the thrill of virtual reality in the
Assassin's Creed universe
but there is more Nexus is not the only
game that will offer new ways to play
Assassin's Creed
Assassin's Creed code name Jade is our
first open world RPG game on mobile
it will take you to ancient China in a
time of intrigue and conspiracy
in this brand new adventure you'll
experience the iconic Assassin's Creed
gameplay for free anywhere anytime
I am glad to announce that you can
register now for the upcoming beta
here's a glimpse of what you can expect
[Applause]
[Music]
Legacy
it's honoring those that came before us
learning from their triumphs
and mistakes
to illuminate and hold their stories to
the light
for all to see
that inheritance of knowledge helps to
guide and shape our future
now it's your turn
to build on those foundations
and rise to even greater Heights to step
out of the shadows and into a vast world
to make your own legacy
[Music]
[Applause]
we've all been waiting for this moment
Assassin's Creed Mirage is a very
special game
designed as a no match to the first
titles of the series that many of us
fell in love with
coming October 12th assassins could
Mirage take the franchise back to its
foots
Sarah or narrative director for the game
will come on stage to tell you more
about Bassin and his journey
but before that let's watch our story
trailer
that's good
[Music]
what are you doing
my Middle Island
tell Basim the story of the feather
our tradition of the feather comes from
Egypt
the feathers of the Heron were dipped in
the blood of the targets
the feathers Forge our paths remind us
of who we are
who we can be
the order has held Dominion orbit men
and their Empires for centuries
strike quickly and endlessly
swallow your questions serve without
complaint who is she to tell you when to
strike
everything you do serves the hidden ones
that is a strange kind of freedom
[Music]
you are not the first to walk the
Shadows broken
pour your pain into the Brotherhood
[Music]
are messengers of Justice
and not the final judges
[Music]
he knows not what he is
have you not wondered that's your nature
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
what does it mean to be free
what must be sacrificed in the Quest for
freedom and Justice the hidden ones
fiercely pursue
how can you find your path and fulfill
your destiny when you don't know who you
really are
as he grows from Street Thief to master
assassin bassim thinks he has found a
sense of purpose as a hidden one working
in the dark to serve the light
but his nightmarish Visions keep
haunting him leading to more questions
with no answer
in Baghdad seeking the truth comes with
the price
the capital of the Abbasid Empire one of
the richest most diverse and most
advanced cities in the world is at a
turning point of its history
unrest is growing sinning a revolution
against corruption and arbitrary Justice
and Uprising that will turn the tides of
history and change the lives of everyone
childhood friends feather hidden ones as
well as newly formed lies and enemies
will shape basim's Adventure but his
horrific Visions are the face of a
struggle that he can only handle alone
there is a lot to look forward to In
Assassin's Creed Mirage and the best way
to make you understand are unique back
to the roots experience is to show you
the game
in the following gameplay walkthrough we
meet pass him right after the
assassination of his first main target
as he reports back to Roshan in Hobby as
assassin Bureau enjoy
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
time to vanish
get back here dog
it's not a fight you worm
running away
two
alhamdulillah
I am glad you are safe
alhamdulillah a first of many
achievements to combust him we should
only hope
there's still much work to do
while our Focus was on our Rule full of
quietly scouted the city for a way we
could erect more bureaus I have found
dwellings in three districts that are
most unassuming
I will make my way to sharkia shortly
and I will join Rebecca in car
where corruption is as common as the
Arid air
see abujah far about some things he's
been working on then come find us
have a look Blossom I may have something
that is of interest to you
[Music]
resourceful as always my thanks Abu Java
this is the place
what do you see in kidu
[Music]
let us reconsider the approach
foreign
[Music]
they will surely fail
oh
what she get the bastards
[Music]
what
hey
guys
the sky is safe my friend
survey the area in kidu
there is my target
thank you
learn your play
oh
[Music]
ah
yes what I wish to know and no more than
he died this day
[Music]
the Lord
[Applause]
thank you
hello everyone
so first I want to start by saying thank
you to all Gamers all around the world
it signs to you that we are here today
you are at the art of everything we do
and to all Ubisoft teams
around the world as well
I would like to say a big thank you
[Applause]
your talent and passion are at the
foundation
of this fantastic lineup
so I hope you are all excited
to explore the amazing playgrounds you
have seen today
at Ubisoft we are creators of worlds we
are also proud to partner with some of
the biggest names in entertainment
to create Original Stories in Beloved
universities
now I am very happy to welcome Julian
from Ubisoft massive
to give you a first look at Star Wars
Outlook and
end game play so thank you
Julian
[Music]
calm down do you want to see gameplay or
not
all right
let's get over the speech and let's get
to the gameplay
Star Wars Outlaws takes place in a time
of great civil unrest
across the Galaxy
for some
this is a time of turmoil
for outlaws
this is a time of opportunity
as a cunning Thief
keeves and her companion NYX fight for
survival every single day relying on
their skills and resourcefulness to get
by
as they struggle to make ends meet
Kay and Nix
dream
of the day that they will finally be
free
but while seeking this freedom
K unexpectedly becomes one of the
Galaxy's Most Wanted
so to free herself
from the Bounty that follows her
Kay will need to pull off one of the
greatest heists the outer rim has ever
seen
as they navigate the underworld core
between criminal syndicates and vicious
ruthless villains K and Nix will manage
their reputation by taking on risky
contracts and navigating complex
relationships
all whilst avoiding oppressive Imperial
rule
can nix's Journey will take them across
the Galaxy through stunning varied open
World locations and the Wilds of space
one of these locations is Tashara
a moon that features Windswept Savannah
and ambering canyons
carved into tashara's striking landscape
the city of miragana serves as a central
hive
of scum and villainy
Titanics will encounter several criminal
syndicates
that learned that everything
is measured in the value of influence
reputation
or cold hard credits
this presents an abundance of
opportunities and dangers
for a young ambitious scoundrel-like k
on behalf of Massif in Sweden
along with Ubisoft ANSI Barcelona
Bucharest Chengdu Milan Montpellier
Paris Shanghai Toronto
laughs
and our amazing
team at lucasfilm games it's our
privilege
to present to you this first ever look
at Star Wars Outlaws gameplay
if you're willing to take the risk
the Galaxy is full of opportunity thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
um
good boy
I want that fighter strip for parts by
tomorrow
all right next let's go get paid
that worked
because he knows how to handle the
Empire we cannot trust those officers
they take our credits now but what stops
them from stabbing Us in the back
next
hit that button
nice one
hang on tight little buddy
hey uh I was just leaving
[Music]
hey Nick
this is getting bad
what's up
let's try this out
stink ferric
[Music]
I think that went pretty well right
foreign
[Music]
that was close
95 I got the package where are you
waiting for you in jaunt us hope
are you seen I said I got it what else
matters
anytime soon
um well they'll probably forgive me
there's Johnson's hope we made it Nyx
formula
foreign
no
okay
no picture Troy what
be careful
tonka's a broker not a friend
she can't be trusted
who can out here
see you back at the ship
round two and I still like my odds
okay vess
back already
I told you she's fresh but she's good
who's this
who's a friend
join us
job was more complicated than you said
Danka
you lived
hey these aren't toys
they're Investments
wait
we haven't met
I don't really know many of you
stealing illegal Contraband running with
syndicates I could say you're a threat
to the Empire
but I won't have to if you're smart
thanks but I'm smart enough to get
myself out of trouble you pay the tax
just like everyone else whoa kid let's
just relax
you won't make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
all Troopers we have reports of a
fugitive in Georgia's hope move to
apprehend
that Imperial announcement wouldn't be
about you would it uh could be I told
you not to trust her
not the first time we've ever on the
empire
we need to leave yeah no kidding
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
are we good nothing on the sensors yet
anybody on the sensors now
Tie fighters on us
got one
I feel inclined to remind you that we
should shake the Empire quickly thanks
I'm working on it
[Music]
Andy get us out of here
let's jump
[Music]
we made it
hey
got your new toy
[Music]
so where do we go next
anywhere we want
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]